Grüß euch, wir sind hier in der "Black
Hawk"-Staffel. Mein Name ist Franz Reisinger
und mein Dienstgrad ist Major. Ich bin hier der
Staffelkommandant und ich nehme euch heute mit
auf einen Rundgang um meinen "Black Hawk".
Wir bereiten uns vor auf denFlugdienst.
Das Erste, das ein Pilot zu tun hat, ist es,
einen Außencheck zu machen und deswegengehen
wir eine Runde. Wenn ihr mich begleitet, freue
ich mich und ich zeige euch die Dinge, dieman vor
einem Flug kontrolliert. Hier haben wir eine der
Einstiegstüren (Cockpittüre) für den Co-Piloten.
Da kann man einen ersten Blick ins Cockpit wagen.
Hier wird geschaut,ob die Tür richtig auf und zu
geht und ob alle Verriegelungen zu sind. Hier
stehen wirbei den Schneebrettern, die um diese
Jahreszeit natürlich montiert sind. Und da checken
wir, ob sie richtig montiert sind. Dafür gibt es
Prüfmarken, an denen man sieht, ob alles richtig
vonder Technik montiert wurde. Wir fliegen
natürlich im Hochgebirge mit diesen Hubschraubern,
und dort,das kennt ihr selber vom Schifahren,
gibt es oft Tiefschnee. Und damit wir dort landen
können, habenwir ziemlich mächtige Schneebretter,
die fast so groß sind wie ein Surfbrett. Aber
sie helfen unsbei der Arbeit. So – wir schauen
weiter. Ich mache einmal die Kabinentür auf. Dann
steige ichrauf und man kann bereits einen ersten
Blick in die Kabine wagen. Darin ist relativ viel
Platz. Mankann bis zu 20 Sitze montieren. Wenn
man Soldaten mit Ausrüstung mit hat, wird man
natürlich wenigerSitze montieren, da weniger
Platz vorhanden ist. In dieser Version haben wir
acht Sitze für Soldaten, aber wie schon gesagt,
bis zu 20 kann man einbauen. Ich steig hinauf
und wage einen Blick zum linken Triebwerk,
wo man den Ölstand kontrolliert. Wir haben
zweiTriebwerke mit jeweils 1.940 PS, die
uns in der Luft halten. Da wir gerade hier
bei der Kabine sind, möchte ich euch etwas
zeigen. Nämlich – hier haben wir so ein kleines
Türchenim Boden, in dem der Außenlasthaken
versteckt ist. Den kann man ausklappen und
bis zu vierTonnen Außenlast anhängen. Für den
militärischen Zweck können wir daran Autos oder
sonstigemilitärische Ausrüstung transportieren.
Im Assistenz- oder Katastropheneinsatz kann
man Bagger oder auch Container punktgenau
absetzen. Das bedarf natürlich einer guten
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Techniker. Wir haben
zwei Bordtechniker mit und der weist den Piloten
bei der Aufnahme sowie beim Absetzen der Last
ein. Aber da braucht man natürlich ein
bisschen Training und das machen wir.
Wie gesagt, das ist das linke Triebwerk. Hierwird
der Sprit eingefüllt - da schauen wir nur,
ob es geschlossen ist. Wir können 2.300 Pfund
Spriteinladen, das reicht ca. für zweieinhalb
Stunden Flugzeit - damit kommen wir um die
500Kilometer weit. Das überprüfen wir hier. Wir
gehen weiter. Hier ist der Auslass des
linkenTriebwerkes. Da wird es natürlich
relativ warm in der Gegend, weil dort die heiße
Luft rauskommt. Hier haben wir das Zusatztriebwerk
– ich habe bis jetzt von zwei Triebwerken
gesprochen, wir haben aber noch ein drittes
mit dem wir quasi die Haupttriebwerke anlassen,
Strom machen und heizen können. Der Luftauslass
ist hier auf der linken Seite und kommt hier
hinaus. Dann gehen wir ein Stück weiter.
Das, das ausschaut wie ein Treppengeländer,
ist eine Antenne für die vielen Funkgeräte,
die wir mittlerweile haben. Wir stehen
ja jetztbei dem Hubschrauber mit einem
neuen Cockpit. Dieser hat einige andere Antennen
darauf, weil er mehr Funkgeräte drinnen hat, das
werden wir uns aber noch im Detail anschauen. Wir
haben ein Räderfahrwerk, wie ihr schon gesehen habt
und auch das hintere Rad braucht, wenn
man im Hochgebirge landenwill, ein Schneebrett,
das hier ein bisschen kleiner ausgeführt ist.
Da schauen wireinfach, ob alle Markierungen
passen, ob das Rad verriegelt ist und die Ölstände
passen. Dann kommen wir hier zum Stabilisator.
Schaut aus wie eine Tragfläche - nennt sich
Stabilisator und ist der einzige Teil bei
diesem Hubschrauber, der "Fly by Wire" ist.
Das heißt, er wird gesteuert vom Computer.
Je schneller man fliegt, desto horizontaler
steht das Ding und je langsamer, desto weiter
unten steht der Stabilisator und soll quasi
den Hubschrauber im Nickmoment stabilisieren.
Weil der Hubschrauber einen
Geschwindigkeitsbereich zwischen 0 und maximal 360
km/h hat, damit er trotzdem immer halbwegs gerade
in der Luftliegt, braucht er diesen Stabilisator
damit man keinen Purzelbaum macht. Hinten ist
der Heckrotor – auch ein mächtiges Gerät, leicht
schräg gestellt wie ihrsehen könnt – ebenfalls
damit ich im Schweben, nachdem der Hubschrauber
so lange ist, nicht ineiner NoseUp-Position, also
nach hinten geneigt bin. Der Heckrotor produziert
Auftrieb, damit ich schön gerade in der Luft
stehen kann. Hier überprüfen wir die Ölstände.
Gehendann vorbei bei den anderen Antennen fürdie
Navigation. Hier haben
wir einige GPS-Antennen.Wir haben natürlich auch
Verbindung zum Satelliten, damit wir navigieren
können und auch Anflügemachen können. Der "Black Hawk" ist natürlich ein Militärhubschrauber, das habt ihr wahrscheinlichschon
gegoogelt oder irgendwo mitbekommen.
Das heißt, er kann auch im gefährlichen
Umfeldfliegen und da unter anderem kann man
einen Chaff and Flare Dispenser montieren. Da kann
manMagnesiumfackeln – heiße Fackeln zur Störung
von Infrarot-Lenkwaffen - ausstoßen oder zur
Störungvon irgendwelchen radargelenkten Waffen.
Chaff and Flare Dispenser heißt dieses Gerät
und dakommen die Patronen hinein und diese
schießen links und rechts heraus. So, jetzt
sind wir beim rechten Triebwerk angekommen.
Hier checkt man auch die Ölstände und ob die
Kabinentür in Ordnung ist. Dieses komische
Gestänge ist nur auf der rechten Seite.
Da kann man eineRettungswinde montieren,
die bis zu 80 Meter Seilenthält.
Daran kann man zwei Personen anhängen,
um so Menschen beispielsweise von
einem Schiff oder einem brennenden
Hochhaus zu retten. Wir haben das auchschon
trainiert von Eisenbahnwaggons herunter,
aus einem Boot heraus. Also auch eine gute
Möglichkeit, um irgendwo einen Beitrag zu leisten.
Ich habe es zuerst schon angesprochen, wir
habennatürlich Bordtechniker mit. Normalerweise
hat man beim "Black Hawk" zwei Bordtechniker mit
und hier ist die Ein- und Ausstiegsluke für den
Bordtechniker. Der steigt hier ein und da istsein
Arbeitsplatz. Wir haben hier so kleine Löcher.
Zwei Fassungen, in diese kann man die
Maschinengewehremontieren. Natürlich
kann man auf dem Militärhubschrauber"Black Hawk"
auch links und rechts eine Bewaffnung
montieren. Dies ist in unserem Fall
als Selbstschutz-Bewaffnung gedacht und die
Bordtechniker sind gleichzeitig auch
Doorgunner und die können uns einen
gewissen Schutz auf beiden Seiten gewährleisten.
Dann kontrollieren wir weiter bis ganz nach vorne.
Wir haben natürlich auch Scheibenwischer
– falls es regnet brauchen wir diese.
Die Scheiben sind auch beheizbar. Man kann mit dem
"Black Hawk" auch einen Instrumentenflug machen.
Das heißt, man fliegt Radar-geführt in den
Wolken und da kann es zur Vereisung kommen.
Damit die Scheibe nicht ganz zufriert, kann man
diese beheizen. Das Gleiche kann man auch bei den
Hauptrotorblättern und beim Heckrotor machen.
So und jetzt kommen wir ganz nach vorne. Es haben
sich wahrscheinlich schon viele
gefragt, was das ist.
Dies ist ein Wetterradar,mit dem man die
verschiedenen Wettererscheinungen
und weitere Informationen in einer Reichweite von
über500 Kilometer vor uns auf dem Bildschirm zur
Anzeige bringen kann, damit der Pilot weiß,
was aufihn zukommt oder wie er ausweichen
kann. Dafür ist das Wetterradar gedacht. So,
und jetzt schauen wir einen Sprung ins Cockpit.
Schön, dass ihr dabei seid. Wir sind jetzt
im Cockpit angekommen und wir sitzen hier
im ersten "Black Hawk", der mit dem neuen
Cockpit ausgestattetist und ich werde
euch jetzt ein paar Dinge erzählen,
die ich auch erzählen darf. Es wurden
im neuen Cockpitzwei verschiedene Systeme
eingebaut. Vorne sind vier Bildschirme mit
den Controls. Es ist einGarmin-Cockpit und
zwar das Garmin 5000. Ein ziviles System, mit
dem man fliegt und als zweites, nachdemwir
natürlich in einem Militärhubschrauber sind,
haben wir noch ein militärisches System eingebaut,
das jetzt ausgeschaltet ist. Wir haben in der
Staffel einen Planungscomputer, auf diesem
werden die Missionen geplant, die taktischen
Karten eingespielt und mittels SD-Cards
über das militärische System einspielt und
dann auf dem zivilen Garmin-Systemvorne
auf den Bildschirmen zur Anzeige gebracht.
Wir haben hier vier Bildschirme. Für
jeden Piloten zwei. Das linke, welches vor
mir ist, ist das Primary Flight Displaymit
den Fluginstrumenten. Über dieses kann
ich den Hubschrauber steuern und
navigieren. Derzweite Bildschirm ist
das Multifunktionsdisplay, wo ich einerseits
die Triebwerksüberwachungsinstrumente habe,
andererseits in verschiedenen Segmenten aussuchen
kann, welche Karten ich einspielen will und das
steuere ich miteinem Touchscreen.
Genau so macht man das auch mit dem
militärischen System, und so lassen
sich die taktischen Karten einspielen.
Das wären die gesamten Neuerungen.
Dann sind natürlich die Steuerorgane, mit
denen ich den Hubschrauber fliegen kann.
Ich habe zwei Pedale und in der
Mitte einen Steuerknüppel, mitdem
ich in verschiedene Richtungen lenken kann.
Hier auf der linken Seite habe ich den Hebel,mit
dem es mir möglich istzu steigen und zu sinken.
An der Oberseite gibt es noch die
Steuerungshebel für die Triebwerke.
Mit diesen kann ich die Triebwerke starten und
weitere Schalter wie etwa für die Beleuchtung.
DerRest sind alles Sicherungen.
Die brauche ich im normalen Flugbetrieb
nicht. Wenn ihr jetzt auch Lust
bekommen habt, Militärpilot zu werden,
dann würden wir uns über junge
und motivierte Mitarbeiter freuen.
Ihr könnt euch informieren auf der Website
https://www.karriere.bundesheer.at
– würde mich freuen!